let's see here which one's next new
phone
maybe we'll find out yeah okay
so i got my new phone today and it looks
like an old one yeah she got one of
those apple eye pores
um i don't like it
it's okay it works slightly better
than the other phone but because the
other phone had been dropped so many
times
um i'm gonna keep the other phone you
know
to oh my god listen up lady
you're homeless you can't even take care
of the few things you do have
yeah get a case stupid no one one of
them obama phones
stop buying pendants and buy phone cases
see that's more important for you
use for a spare to watch videos or play
music on
it's just harder to charge so i can't
use it as often
um but what do you guys think i uploaded
my first episode of pokemon that i
i think is i well if you're asking me i
think it's wonderful
actually i want her to succeed in all of
her streaming
and she plays pokemon which is kind of
like the stds because she's got to catch
them all
she's really good at it that's very
great recorded she loves this no why
she's good at it but she's just good at
it
syphilis i choose you
karia
[Laughter]
um oh no can y'all tell a difference
and how the uh games are shown
or how the recording is um like the
quality
it looks the same yeah all of your
videos look like hostage videos
it's honestly shittier turn the phone
sideways
she's watching this hey um
andreas day or mary or whatever your
name please
turn your phone sideways thank you a
mailhead turn your phone sideways
see i wasn't even trying to be mean
you're just i wasn't being me it's a
nickname
quality with my with me oh
so it's saturday night
got two more days to get through and
then it's my birthday
wait is it a birthday today uh it's over
the weekend yes you'll get to that here
in just a second okay
today is my well it's
in florida it's already sunday which
makes it my friend chucky's birthday
happy birthday chucky happy birthday
um
i am trying to get up as much as i can
to get everything stocked up here so i
don't have to go out
on my birthday because my birthday is
often not a very good day for me
um in what in relation to
every other day yeah tuesday wednesday
anything that ends in a day
yeah it's it's the anniversary of the
murder
it's the anniversary of when
meh tried to infect me what murder
the no that's when the guy with the hiv
tried to infect her
got it it's it's the anniversary of a
lot of
bad memories in my life okay so i try to
just stay home and stay where i can just
kind of cry all day you know
um this time of year
it gets real hard for me that's what's
making it even harder with these guys
that have started attacking me recently
it's
is that us i think so and by the way
non-cons she didn't murder someone she
helped bury them
you'll find that out if you read her
book so she's an accomplice
yes okay murder cool cool that they
chose to
do it right now you know
when i'm already having a super hard
time
probably because of the murder yeah
it's tough from the anniversary reaction
um i've been feeling sick citizen king
says
guys you just don't understand duck
diets you're right
i don't fair point what somebody that
studies birds
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm a bird watcher okay cool you're a
virgin i get it
wasting their time while jerking off in
the woods yeah seriously
are you [ __ ] those birds dick i've
been feeling tired i've been sleeping
i'm tired i'm wasted i love you darling
being a lot my bones hurt
does your face hurt because it's hurting
me
and i i always thought that that was
just like me
i don't know being tired ornithologist
is somebody who studies birds
thank you kevin you yeah thank you nerds
you [ __ ] nerd
this is a way to [ __ ] see who the
nerds are
but when i was talking to the therapist
last week she said that
some people their cptsd causes their
bones to hurt it causes some physical
pain
oh fiber that's right fibromyalgia yeah
crowderiosis
yeah yeah you have you have cracking you
have the crowder disease
um when triggered you know oh she's
triggered okay
um the pain i'm feeling could be caused
from
the anniversary reaction i don't even
know
there's a scientific word for nerd dork
yeah could it be sleeping on a floor in
a sleeping bag is why you're so achy
something like that so much going on
with me right now i just kind of like
i want everything to just stop
but that's not how life works you know
at least she's aware
yeah but so she
someone has a good point like why is it
always all these like
loser women that are always have these
weird
diseases like
fibromyalgia or ptsd i'm sure you have
the [ __ ] same disease as someone who
served the nom
yeah [ __ ] why don't you just get
blood cancer like be a man
yeah seriously or aids as everybody else
says i have
yeah or crippling depression like i have
to [ __ ] figure it out
figured [ __ ] out have you ever had
ibs and tried to leave the house it's a
son of a [ __ ]
it is the worst thing that could happen
it's worse than 911. i'll be honest with
you
okay so update on pokemon um
i somehow deleted my file
i lost everything it must have been
those thieves those thieves walked into
the house and deleted your files after
they started the necklace
it's the maintenance man with the usb
drive in the closet
he was really mad that you had a mr mime
and he didn't
so he took you out well i've restarted
it and i'm just about back to where i
was
but i can't catch another pikachu
oh that's the problem
i can't with this that's her problem is
she can't catch a pikachu
yeah well i mean you got to catch them
all
can't be hey can't beat the game if you
don't catch a pikachu it's literally the
first one you get
zach says she had a level 100 snorlax
i tried you know um i spent about an
hour
running around in the viridian forest
i just didn't catch that's way better
than filling out [ __ ] job
applications
i can't i don't want her to work stay at
home and play pokemon
right you're right which one which is
such [ __ ] right
is she gonna cry yes is she crying over
pokemon
yes because when i played the last round
pikachu were everywhere and so i'm sorry
is this another is this another
conspiracy theory that they're
keeping the pikachu away from her see
what happened was
the maintenance man changed her locks
stole her pendant
came back a day later because she he
knew
it was her birthday the next day and he
went
and he got his nerd son to program the
pikachus
out of the game replaced the game got
back out
all before she even knew it
the next video is is like turns out i
was just playing metroid
mark's got a merge merc said merc's got
a good point he goes she doesn't get
that it's only a five percent spawn rate
in the virgin forest of pikachu's
she would know that if she paid
attention [ __ ] nerds
now i'm running around for an hour and
finding nothing
but bug pokemon so [ __ ]
the force dummy story oldest time
if you go to the mountain biome you get
wolves if you go down to the bottom you
get dwarves and trolls
exactly and don't go to the planes yet
we're not leveled up enough
no those goddamn mosquitoes got [ __ ]
heat seekers on their faces
[ __ ] you up
we lost regular size rudy
but we still have bob oh no
chichi she lost regular size rudy
regular size she's still got uh dildo
sized
oh no guys we still have bob
we still have gene and the show will go
on
okay cause i was worried the show was
gonna
uh sad pokemon update then leads into
[Music]
uh birthday plans oh nice can't wait
it's gonna be a big blast
okay so was were we invited i think
maybe
no we're asked to sleep okay it's been a
rough couple of days for my nerves
what a cute little top yeah what a cute
little top
hey i know this is some [ __ ] big show
just signed with aew
no [ __ ] seriously seriously big show
has officially signed with aw oh [ __ ]
that's that's actually
crazy yeah you heard that first right
here breaking [ __ ] news [ __ ] tiger
woods legs
big show has gone is all elite now
all elite baby great so he could
work terribly there like he worked in
dummy
apparently it's a commentator deal so
that's going to be even better
what you sign a [ __ ] giant to be a
commentator
apparently so i mean they signed a
[ __ ] taz's there
that's a good point or royce lopez
hey hey but it's my birthday
happy birthday happy birthday happy
happy birthday
but i can't breathe every time i think
of the big show the only thing i think
it was on the rock made fun of him with
the
i need weed literally just a good grip
is this your video jj
this is not my video i always have weeds
so
jj is one of those when he's when he
just has half an ounce he's like
running low one
oh no three
four five kinds so
five weeds you gotta you gotta catch
them all jj
yes i want to catch them all
jj is gonna make a video crying like i
can't find my sour diesel
i just had it yesterday i lost my
shark's breath damn it
i don't know if i smoked it or not i
have no idea i got
i got too high and don't remember if i
smoked i think the maintenance man came
in
[ __ ] [ __ ] graham would help
uh paypal slasher drives to you i did
she just dropped she dropped her paper
yes she did nice don't and she gonna do
it again
you'll you'll you'll see i'm gonna get
dressed and
she got some pretty big traps yeah yeah
she's like brock lesnar
neck go uh
check out the freebies today because of
course birthdays always bring free stuff
i have a i have a starbucks drink to go
get
denny's don't forget denny's and a
denny's meal
[Laughter]
don't forget 7-eleven for your free
slurpee oh man
you gotta make the rounds bro and i
think that's it i can't think of
anything else
um and i do have i still have a dollar
i'm gonna go and buy myself a new
necklace charm thank god i've been
looking at hoping i could find the old
one
blow your nose please right but it is
with your hair it's there's no way
that it's anywheres in this apartment
because this is the smallest apartment
and i have searched it repeatedly
like i put off buying the new charm
because i was like it can't just
disappear it's got to be here somewhere
so uh i'm going to go get a new charm
i'm going to go get my she's a lot of
stuff
she's on that murse juice is
starbucks i'm gonna go get my denny's oh
that's a merc says
uh her traps make her look like the bad
guys from deep space nine you're saying
she's like a cardassian
that's it she's a cardassian neck
and then when i get back we'll jump back
into pokemon
um i did lose pikachu we know and i
can't get him back
but but last night i gained
a louise so in the next video we have a
louise now
thank god that's what we needed jj and i
were talking off there and going like
can you believe she lost her pikachu
what are we gonna do we were worried
we should get her some wolf armor do you
hear me frozen i want
wolf armor ready for me the next time i
log in thank you very much
don't worry homie i got a bunch of wolf
pelts last night and silver
we got your back nice we got your back
i will see i will keep y'all into spits
on what i caught
to turn her until we filmed
okay i'm oh i'm i'm waiting here with
baited breath
honestly i'm waiting with baited breath
um let's see here hey guys can we get
her to 300 come on guys
guys she's only at 299. yeah come on
guys
come on man what are you guys doing i'll
post the link because honestly
you're not going to be able to find her
with her adrasta dia name or whatever
[ __ ] thing is here uh the next one is
we are more than our camera within our
careers
all right so i went out and i got a
couple of things
for my birthday oh i got a new charm
gonna make me a new necklace it's pink
like the other one but it's a different
shape and it's more solid i like it
and i got my birthday weed
the weed please that looks like good it
looks like good weed
for a homeless person jj not
uh they're like come on man homeless
people are supposed to be able to get
the good weed that's why they're
homeless
ah a good point
isn't it pretty i mean i give it a six
and not her i'm giving her a two two for
her six for the weed
a nine for her pokemon though
uh i'm gonna be going back out because
i'm going to go to the store and get
this stuff to make
my dinner and
i kind of want to try to make myself a
gluten-free birthday cake
but what
she's into the gluten-free thing because
when she eats gluten it makes her sick
you can't be homeless and be gluten-free
well you can if you're fancy like her
you're right i didn't think about how
fancy she was
she's fancy look at that [ __ ] haircut
but
i have no plans and
ants i don't know i don't know if it's
working i think pan
like to cook things with a pan yeah
things you cook with cool
yeah with it you know i have ice cream i
could just have a ice cream and jello
birthday cake
which is fine maybe next year
ice cream i mean jello yeah right that's
what you're thinking too right
what's an hot that's sounds disgusting
yeah yeah i can't i don't
know i don't want that equipped to
actually
cook but like i've got no blender i've
got no pans
i've got um three pots
to cook in and you can't bake a cake in
a pot
you know actually
you can't if you try hard enough you
could
anything's possible so you can make meth
in a pan
okay so anything's possible go buy a
bunch of sudafed i
have a recipe for a cake for you some
batteries
um i'm trying to decide whether i want
to film pokemon now or wait a little bit
i think i'm going to wait a little bit
why would you keep us in suspense
you got to keep us coming back for more
yeah you're right so i'm going to go out
to the store and grab some chicken
to make something to eat why don't you
just eat some of the ducks you killed
right um they're already stuffed dirty
stuffed with rice
yeah i was gonna say she doesn't want to
be poisoned by the rice
i'm trying to avoid the tv because
i came back in i sat down i was gonna
grind a little bit of my weed up and
smoke a bowl and watch tv so i turned
the tv on right
and it's the news and there's a car
crashed like badly into a ditch across a
park
like into a into a gate and [ __ ] is this
gonna be tiger woods
it's tiger woods i'm like holy [ __ ]
and then i i keep watching and they're
like oh it's tiger woods
oh [ __ ] is he okay uh
i never found out if he's okay or not
because the inner the the
newscaster was like well we hope his
career will be able to survive after
this but he is 45 years old and that's a
hard road
back what what what about his career i'm
sorry
he was just in an accident that he's is
he even alive why are we focusing on his
career
what i mean mostly because that's the
only thing of value that he has
you know i've watched a lot of her
videos this is the first time i've kind
of agreed with her oh no i agree that's
what i was saying earlier
but i don't know she doesn't strike me
as a big golf fan
who doesn't know who tiger woods is at
this point maybe she's just big into
black dudes
yeah there you go
what is what was that yeah
illness [ __ ] and because he's a
cheating [ __ ]
you know the only thing i know about him
is that he sleeps with like a hundred
different women a day right
but that's simmons that's not tiger
woods
and even if it wasn't he's tiger woods
he could do whatever the [ __ ] he wants
like
you know let him do if he wants to bang
every shony's waitress that's on him
who cares let him get syphilis and
gonorrhea you know about that don't you
marry
exactly i don't deserve to be like seen
as
just his career if he's injured if he's
hurt then it should be more like
we hope he recovers we hope he's not
yeah kobe 2021 right yeah it wasn't a
helicopter at least
a rear recovers you know at this point
he's made enough money
surely what why are why are we worried
about the career
because some people just want to be
winners
tom brady you know tom brady didn't need
to [ __ ] keep playing football the guy
has more money than god
but he wants to be a winner yeah he
wants the the
championships he wants to be the goat
also tiger woods is 45 now wow
when we're we should be worried about
the human being
why do you know and that's what like
go visit him in the hospital feed him
rice
gets me thinking like what are we
you know we focus well i think we are we
are the youth of the nation if i
remember correct
eod baby yeah this on our careers
on our our jobs as you know as if that's
what makes us what we are
it's not what makes us what we are tell
me we're people
oh and why can't we be seen as people
you know when dolly parton or betty
white or any of the greats die
there it's most of the focus is going to
be on their career
yes because we don't know them
personally
like what else am i supposed to focus on
her [ __ ] fash
[ __ ] betty white's fashion sense
uh i don't have anything for this yeah
human beings too and it shouldn't be on
just
what they accomplished but you know
them as people i don't know maybe i'm
just going
it just kind of like it it upset me
it was a new thing she's almost as upset
as losing a pikachu
yeah or a necklace yeah that mean that
happens a lot
maybe pikachu stole her necklace
i'm gonna laugh when a week from now she
forgets to keep that thing off of the
[ __ ] thing and just she pans around
and there it is
it's right there yep yep that's just
gonna happen
so i think the rest of this is just her
showing the uh
the news report yeah good news though
there is good news um and the good news
is
is that yeah weed life part one so about
that weed that y'all were talking about
it ain't good weed if it's got seeds
that's all i'm gonna say
let's see her weed okay so with the
weather warming up i thought now would
be as good a time as any
to start germinating my
plants now normally wait she's
she's going to grow the weed she's going
to grow weed in her living room that she
doesn't use she's going to turn that
into a grow house right inside the front
door
and people are gonna they're gonna not
steal that and come through and steal
the new necklace
makes sense i will put them in paper
towels
uh i've got five seeds so five seeds
and a gram [ __ ] off that's gotta be
shitty weed you're right
it just went down to three i was reading
that you could just
pour them into the water uh-huh
but first off there's too much water
there it doesn't need to fill the whole
half of the glass
seriously she's throwing three seeds
into a gallon
like leave them
for a couple of days and germinate them
like that so
we're gonna try that i will keep you all
updated
good i'm worried i'm i'm intrigued yep
every day i will make videos or take
pictures that i will edit together
probably once a week or depending on how
fast they grow
i mean i can tell you how fast they're
gonna grow but i want you to find out
and tell the people
yeah don't don't spoil it for her and
spoil her [ __ ] bit
should we see her birthday meal or her
new necklace birthday meal all right
all right so i went to the store and i
picked up
a steak for my dollar steak oh
what kind of steak what quality is this
it looks like t-bone
huh dinner tonight it's a tasty bun oh
it is
and some an onion and some carrots
and some potatoes and some aluminum foil
and i'm going to wrap them all
oh she's doing an art project like
dating all right
we're going to put the aluminum foil now
and put them in the oven season them up
with some onion and garlic sauce it's
gonna be good
and also hahaha
oh shitty wine sweet strawberry wine
oh ew
daddy scroll hold on i'm looking this
one i'd rather drink mad dog dude
okay gallow family sweet strawberry wine
you could pick that up bad boy you could
pick that bad boy up for 4.99
oh that's not bad man 449 if you go to
total wine
i bet you that wine tastes really good
yeah
yeah totally make your [ __ ] diary out
your ass
charles is right that's just a headache
maker
i got me a bottle of wine so pokemon
tonight
girls let me give a shout out to him
makes a hell of a [ __ ] good logos man
who charles hancock creations oh yeah he
does great
i want to oh okay new necklace
i made my new necklace let's write the
new necklace what do we think
i like the other one
a better job on the uh shitty hobo uh
hmm i don't like this one it looks like
a little turd
yeah well they don't look like a turd
yeah but this is a bigger turret a
little little bigger turd necklace
what do you think i think i like it i
think it might be a little thin
i usually make them a little thicker but
it's okay so um
dinner's cooking i'm so excited i
seared the t-bone and it's not in the
oven yet because the potatoes and the
carrots are gonna take a little longer
to cook
than the t-bone is um so i'm cooking
those first
and then i'm going to slide the t-bone
in when the carrots and potatoes are
almost done
if i can handle it because i'm already
starving
yeah she crocheted the rope thing
maureen oh
that's what steve marine you [ __ ]
scared i'd be scared
i'd be [ __ ] scared if i were you
save that one for the end save that
one's the end say a bad one that's the
last one
sorry i don't know that's fine that's
the last one okay
oh oh steak and taters steak and taters
let me tell you what we're gonna we're
gonna end on a fantastic it's probably
her best video i'm excited all right so
this is their steak and taters
not gonna hate on me
does she eat her steak well done yeah
i'm gonna say that steak is uh that's an
oh you ruined it it's already cheap meat
you ruined it
you [ __ ] wrote it and also can i ask
something else
is she eating it with a utility knife
yes
you i'm glad you caught that cause i was
gonna point it out what is she [ __ ]
rambo
well you can't cut it with a butter
knife so you gotta use your [ __ ] hobo
knife
it's a utility knife do you know how
many people she stabbed with that
there's the blood of her enemies on that
that's how she gets her meat inside
hiv positive blood yeah
for liking my strike well done she
doesn't i was
we were right she does eat it well done
she eats well done steak
look she's she's slimy she's done a lot
of things that are crazy but this might
be the craziest
yeah it's so i mean i look i like mine a
little medium because i don't
i don't need it mooing at me but i'm
fine with medium i'm on
medium and below i'm i'll be happy with
anything above that is a mess i feel
that way about bacon
all right yeah it's cr if it's crispy at
all [ __ ] yourself
you don't like crispy bacon i like
crispy bread hey i will sir if you
ever make crispy bacon around me i will
throw it out the window
oh no i can't handle blood
it's good though
there we go it was good you know it
doesn't look good
better it looks like overdone [ __ ]
shoe leather
uh we doing birthday and video yeah do
do them both they're both worth it okay
okay hi hey
hey a finished my wine
is she drunk and i finished my steak oh
god she's drunk
i'm about to jump back into pokemon
maybe
we know why she's forgetting where she
puts things now huh
bingo maybe we know why
it's midnight so it's technically not my
birthday anymore
well i technically don't care yeah i
wanted to say thank you you're welcome
to all of my supporters you're welcome
who sent me messages today
you're welcome to say happy birthday
and sent me money to help me get
a little drunk and a little stoned
and i love you guys
and i know that's so sweet what a
sweetie pie
that there's a lot of people on my
channel who don't like me
hold on a second we've never said that
we don't like you
i like you for the content you make lady
i like you a lot
yeah i like you a lot a hard worker
you're consistent
you you provide hours of entertainment
and only watch me because they like
laughing at me
but that's okay too oh thanks
because everybody deserves to be able to
laugh
i don't do it as often as i should but i
try
okay um
i forgot what else i was gonna say
thank you guys i had a really good
birthday
good i'm now officially 36 years old
you don't look a day over 40 no
i don't feel it i feel like i'm like 36
in oboe years is like
64. yes exactly
but i'm working on it thank you guys
you know you guys really are what has
kept me going
for the past couple of years i don't
have anybody
in real life i don't have any friends or
anybody here that is supportive of me
and it really means a lot
everybody on my youtube on my facebook
and on recolor you all
are my life you know
nice and i just want you to know that
even though
i'm not like you and i don't feel
love the same way that you do of course
not she's always special
they always have something there's a
they don't feel love
i do still have a very special place in
my heart
for all of you oh and
pokemon is going to be a little late but
it will be up
very soon thank god drunk pokemon coming
the next video is possible the best
video she's ever made i just realized
it's a minute 34 seconds so let's see
it's the best one she's ever made
so i just realized how stupid it is
for me to be like describing
what my pendant looked like
because none of y'all are anywheres
near me and these things are
sold in bulk like
if you can't tell that this is a
different
necklace than the one i was wearing a
couple of months ago
without just staring at my tits
stop looking
that tells your best video she's ever
made
oh my god her hobo only fans is going to
be lit
yeah the whole time
boxer goes if you destroy the crystal
then she would disintegrate
there's a bigger problem than me
not being able to accurately describe a
pendant
what and i'm not trying to be rude i
just realized that
it's kind of ridiculous that people are
online or asking me
what it looked like when i wore it
around my neck
just like this for like three months
do y'all just get lost at the tits
oh my god
just wait for it royce there's gonna be
a way that you can
you know that you can you can help her
out
oh my god
i mean dude look objectively they're not
terrible too
i've seen worse i mean i've seen worse
too but no
cause like have you have you ever heard
of mindless uh mindlessly
diapered kids yes we've played it on the
show
okay have you ever looked at her twitter
there no i haven't
okay go look at her twitter you're not
welcome
but can somebody ask rob gavigan if you
would though
because i mean i'm really curious would
you rob
can she get it while you're wearing that
stupid hair hat on your head
your bracelets
and not actually see the necklace
there's a pendant moving around up there
do y'all see it or is it just titties
is she drunk and horny is that what's
happening here i i think it is
and if it's just titties can you send me
a couple of dollars to my paypal
her paypal freudian slip eh hey pay
pills
hey hey is that marsha's uh coin coming
up is that the
you know the pay pill yeah that's it
that's that's that's that's
the coin i think we've got so taste
mesmerized hypnotized
paypal me slash drastia
later ostia oh my god
gg what is happening uh
this is the start of a wonderful uh
story arc uh that it's literally the
song that never ends but the hobo
version
oh my god she gets drunk and she gets
horny and then she's asking for money
because she
showed her cleavage yes paypal.com slash
drawsdia why did you do this to me why
did you do this to me
because i like torturing you hey you
need to check out that other video i
sent you to
because you need to get into the belly
boys club oh i will i will i'm going to
check it out i'll do it tomorrow
all right belly club what's what's on
the docket today what's up it's a [ __ ]
wednesday
it's midgets and [ __ ] you hey don't hang
up
god damn it [ __ ] he got me
i was trying to have a plug of [ __ ] uh
how dlive.tv's left jj stoner
coming up next